foreign
hi everyone
um
uh currently a Simon Spartan postal
fellow and today I would like to talk
about my research agenda Quantum for
science
uh generally and Quantum computation is
a kind of Cutting Edge that means in the
exciting area
um so quantum computers is currently a
one specific device like a main use of
quantum mechanical phenomena such as
superposition and entanglement to
perform certain computation so this
feature shows some current state of the
Arts the quantity device we have
um so the reasons that we're concerned
with Quantum reputation is because they
can significantly outperform classical
computers for certain tasks here we know
some potential exponential speed does
like DTG Factory which is an MP problem
but we have a polynomial type analysis
we also have some polynomial time
polynomial reasons for Quantum
simulation and Quantum linear algebra
problems which are b2p complete
uh so today I will focus on the quantum
linear system solvers and layer
applications
um so here is a very basic description
of algorithm so suppose we are given a
sparse and by a system where the
sparsity is only is remote As is quite a
lot in terms of Dimension
um so our goal is to produce Quantum
encoding of the solution and
proportional to the inverse solution so
the capacity of solving such upon state
is still as popularism in terms of
Dimension which is a potential
exponential speed up in terms of n
so of course we can generalize the
algorithm to more other types of
numerical linear algebra organizations
like SVD
so we have some knowledge of this uh of
chronoline algebra however and for
potential upon evolution in the future
we want to figure out what is the
potential kill apps of quantum computers
and can we work on some The Cutting Edge
large-scale computation models like how
to model and damage breeding uh how to
characterize the climate change and even
how to change large language models
which applications like child gbt and so
and for these problems and we have some
fundamental challenges to deal with the
first challenge is about the large gap
between the linearity of quantum
mechanics to a non-linear realistic
systems and the other challenges is in
engineering part how to design an
end-to-end settings to for instance how
to interact classical data and Quantum
data
so um actually non-linearity is
essentially difficult in Quantum
Computing if we really want to achieve a
exponential speed up and so there are
two reasons one is like over 20 years
and the previous Colonial reasons and
for nonlinear Dynamics type exponential
time space and time capacity
um so there are some inefficiency in the
previous design you know comparison
class theories and we also show some
results over the years like the window
not only at least can imply
polynomialized solutions for MP complete
and even for Sharpie problems so with
spell we cannot significantly solve the
most General nominee problems and for
particular systems certain equations we
can probably have some worst case type
complexities managing team
so our contributions to partially
resolve this problem in the weekly and
dissipating non-linear regime so our
contribution is to develop first
efficient polynomialism efficient means
polynomial time for weekly dissipating
nonlinear differential equations we also
established almost high low amount to
show the surely nonlinear wires are
generating travel so this is the paper
public synchronous also with some first
page coverage report important
so here is a basic problem model and we
are focusing on phototype quadratic EOD
systems and with Dimension so here a
linear complementation f is required to
be the solar sparse sparse means on all
the real parts of item values should be
negative and for instance if you wait
you are not about fluid dynamics like
the livestock's equation can satisfy
less confidence
uh so people in such a sister you can
see F2 is a quadratic coupling and one
is linear humbling and F0 is a
non-linear inequality so we want to
resist this season to be weekly
non-linear that means we want F1 to be
lost and f2f0 to be small so we quantify
this not only at least by the parameter
r divided here so you can see and the
meaning of I is that the linear
dissipation can dominate the not only at
least as well as new homogeneities if I
is more so a small R means a weight
non-linearity
so given conditions we developed
so-called Quantum color monetization
methods this realization is totally
different from all the previous
realization because previous algorithms
only worked homes and locally from
creation and linear system but now we
consider globally invading and
linearization techniques transform
Infinity dimensional dynamical control
so the base routing is left the first
step is to invade the undimensional
nonlineod system into an Infinity
dimensional linear system is is
infinite Dimension space the second step
is to properly translate a system to
obtain a poly and dimensional system and
here all previous algorithms work on
explanation and translation which is
inefficient and so given such relation
we prove the convergence rate even the
previous the uh previous the condition R
is more than one
so I is essentially is a convergence
radius so finally and we can perform
funnel linear CCL reason to fall and
linearized ode and which compresses
parallel racing and so the overall
capacity can still as poly loading and
polynomial in time so here is the basis
the informal destruction of our theorem
so assume I is more than one we propose
a planarism that can produce a Quantum
State exponential uh proportion to the
final State and with complexity Sterling
Point poly in key and polarity in terms
of dimension
so uh independent of quantum Computing
and we also the contribution of
improving the best known convergence of
harmonization can also have some
contribution in a classical nonlinear
control series
so on the other side we also show list
results almost time because we prove
nearly had lower bar results so we have
known when I is more than one lazy
efficient Foundation that we proposed
but if ice largely or smaller largely or
equal to strenu of two and we also show
a worst case instance such like any
finalists must solve for a worst case
type complexity explanation and the base
idea is describing here and so we call
the empty file so we try to make use of
the hardness of distinguishing a
non-occern Quantum states which basic
law about time means rise in Quantum
capacity series and is relevant to the
social unstructured search and on the
other side we also make use of a prime
as 10 minutes sort of butterfly effect
that means a small initial difference
can result in a large variation so why
so we create a is such a empty file
which is essentially is a noun in ode
that can change the small this
difference has to to a large defense
case one case is hard to be
distinguishing yeah it's easy to
demonstrate so actually the capacity of
close English amplifier is Financial in
time I will also generalize techniques
to the quantum State discrimination
problem which is fundamental problems in
the quantum capacity
so I also want to cover some brief
applications about LL reasons and the
theories one large field is a social
Quantum scientific limitation so and the
one results that we study is to apply
our algorithms for flu and plasma
Dynamics will show some potential
applications for simulating low Lane
nodes number lamina photos and actually
Leno's number is relevant to our
parameter R so I give the same kind of a
thought in earlier meetings or APS
deviation of fluid dynamics so we also
we have to see and there are other
arbitrations are developed by others
like people using our algorithms to find
the charters and in control theory and
also study the reachability and we can
also apply our LL reasons to simulated
pandemic spreading and also with the
social Ser model which wrap is
vaccination and finally we also study
like the social credit Cycles around
advising economy and ecologies to let a
bunch of applications that are
developing right now
on the other side and in one of my in
preparation was we also study the social
applications you know Quantum machine
learning so we call out all ambition is
to make to try to change large language
models by contributors so here is a
basic routine like given a certain
machine learning model like D5 you can
define a loss and given training set the
initial ways and we just you actually
focus on our standard
um gradient Descent of statistic
gradient descent routing as here so here
we simply consider the MSC loss uh one
example is the multi-layer perception
model like you can see is all
polynomials of different layers and we
virtualize all the parameters by the uh
by sitting here so the basic framework
of the software Quantum within the same
slab we first perform a columnarization
for the disability gradient Dynamics and
then we have some certain guarantee like
while initial ways can be sparse so we
have efficient phones stay preparation
routine and then we also have some
guarantee like while the model is passed
so we can perform efficient quantity and
system servers finally we have some
guarantee like Wireless output should be
smart so we can perform efficient Spa
stage tomography to produce plastic
parameters so this total end to end
classical two classical algorithm
so and we try to add your potential
point of advantage in the sort of by
turning that means less so in a
pre-training process of some certain
large level models unfortunately the
data structures and most structures are
usually dense and but after subscribing
and in a certain fighting process that
we have some um we have sound conditions
like all the data sets and the
structures can be sparse and we also and
have some guaranteed a wireless certain
system can be dissipated so it's
relevant to a sort of information both
necessary lab means when your system
including your brand or computer is
actually learning things you need to
forget your relevant formation so
actually you can show the trace of
facial information measures is higher
and higher actually animation and the
dollar which is setting all the
approximation should have more positive
mode so that means the system is
dissipated enough to help us to
linealize suddenly we also have a lot of
Relativity happens says to expand why
the sparse turning Network can compete
with the original Network
so we have some numerical experience for
either some small sphere or neural
network applied to Iris datasets as well
as the standard risk and models with
over 100 million parameters prior to C4
data set transition process finally I
want to end up with my research agenda
and you can see a photo zone is so
important for size I studied some
fundamental problems from the quantum
simulation to Planet algebra and then I
cross over the Gap from linear to
non-linearity to solve some not only
audience PDS with applications in nature
science like epidemic and fluid dynamics
finally I also developed an end-to-end
design of the quantum within descent and
with applications in sports 520 neural
networks and toward potential
applications to the large-scale machine
learning models so that's all thank you
okay
discussion when a lady sets up soon
oh yes so
you started with a Hello like you
started with a linear system you started
with a linear system now uh linear
system is easily solved
and then you turn into
ode
OD is I assume is not solved easily by
classical computers
what is the complexity of this ode known
complexity
chance and first of all and the one
you'll talk about efficiently uh Thomas
of solving system Audi and I would say
uh yes so if we consider you can see the
non-linear OD systems and the difficulty
and we have some very few guarantee like
we know it's p space or Sharpie and the
follow a linear case is uh it should be
much simple like like it usually built
to P or P2P
maybe they get offline
I had another question
yeah thanks
okay so now we have a sequence of talks
uh by